title of today's debate on the security  situation in Syria carries with it the  painful irony of reality because  colleagues the reality is that there is  no security in Syria there's no security  for the millions of civilians first  Boston to the province and now besieged  bombed and starved in Italy  there's only despair destruction and  death for the injured in the sixty-eight  attacked hospitals for the 373 killed  for the 700,000 refugees stuck in the  freezing mod with no place to go no  clothes and no food once again the  Syrian regime and its Russian and  Iranian backers are using their inhumane  tactics by explicitly targeting  civilians and hospitals they act in  direct violation of humanity colleagues  I hope one day soon we will see Bashar  Assad in my city The Hague so some  justice can at least be done to the  suffering of millions of Syrians thank  you